a lot of us are going through just
changes in our habits because we're now
all stuck at home I know I have again my
eating habits are shifting just because
I'm not going to work every day and
because I'm here with my family I'm kind
of eating what they are eating is that
happening with you yeah 100% I'm so much
healthier my wife is like really
dedicated to her health and now that
we're eating all our meals together I
feel so much better
especially you remember being in New
York you just walk around you're like
should I get pizza or empanadas or like
everything's just in front of you and
your face yeah oh yeah for me I realized
the worst my eating habits got a couple
months ago this bakery opened up in my
neighborhood it's really good and it was
it was between the Train and my hat so I
had to walk past it all the time and one
night on my way home I stopped in there
and they were selling these like creme
brulee cups like in a tin you know where
they take it and put the blowtorch right
there anyhow I got to get one so eating
it on my way home and then halfway there
I was like creme brulee is not like a
grab-and-go item you know like this is
disgusting you don't just this is not
like a granola bar at a bodega like
you're supposed to eat creme brulee
twice a year when someone else pays for
it this is not okay this is horrible and
I actually I finished it and threw it in
the garbage can at the end of my blocks
I didn't want my wife to know that I'm
just like oh horrific and that's the
behavior of an alcoholic like I got to
get rid of the bottle so my my spouse
doesn't see it just I would say maybe a
week and a half ago my wife made lunch
for our son and she put kale and
chickpeas in a blender for him a
one-year-old and I sat next to them and
ate a bowl of Reese's puffs cereal good
that was god bless you you're keeping
respect massive yeah yeah she's teaching
him how to be a healthy living human and
I'm teaching him how to die younger than
he asked
[Laughter]